okay 2020 has felt like a decade
i know and it feels like a lifetime has
happened so
i'm gonna try my best to wrap this whole
thing up for you by setting
a scene so if you just entertain me for
a second
picture this you're a gamer in the year
2020. it's january new year
new you same yearly goals and
aspirations like getting up early
traveling more and finally getting
through that stack of pulp novels you
bought because they made you feel
interesting but there's one thing that
makes this year
unlike many before it there's new game
consoles coming out
you already know what the xbox series x
looks like thanks to the game awards but
the ps5
is still a mystery surprise kentucky
route 0 releases its fifth and final
chapter concluding the surreal american
adventure with all its corky inhabitants
and your dog named blue
meanwhile you're excited to team up with
your friends and venture into the icy
tundras of monster hunter world's new
expansion
iceborn and cyberpunk 2077 is delayed
from april
to september that's okay you can wait
another nine months and not
a second longer it's february and that
game you heard about seven years back
that you thought would never come out
dreams
is here and not only does it remind you
why you didn't pursue that career in
game design but it introduces you to an
overwhelmingly
vast world of amazing creatives making
jaw-dropping art movies
and games and even resurrecting lost
ones within
a game meanwhile you hear that long-time
gears of war producer and director of
gears 5 rod ferguson
leaves the coalition to oversee diablo
over at blizzard entertainment because
well someone's gotta speaking of
departures
dan hauser one of the co-founders of
rockstar games and writer of the grand
theft auto
and red dead redemption franchises
resigns from the company and is likely
sitting on a mountain made of cash
you wonder will rockstar games ever be
the same
only time and maybe another console
release of grand theft auto 5 will tell
maybe oh yeah and uh remember that
coronavirus thing your more culturally
aware friend told you about back in
november 2019
something about black market meat you
weren't paying much attention yeah well
it's making its way around the globe and
it's about to derail your whole world
now a short time ago the world health
organization declared the outbreak an
international public health emergency
and it's called
covid 19. next thing you know publishers
and developers are dropping out of pax
east because of the virus yet still
it trucks on you think to yourself the
whole thing will just blow over soon
march call of duty war zone comes out of
nowhere thrusting the franchise into the
free to play
battle royale market some of your
friends are playing murder by numbers
others pokemon mystery dungeon
you're catching up on coffee talk you're
in yosemite for a weekend getaway when
suddenly you get a message from your
boss telling you not to
come back to work wait am i getting
fired oh
it's actually just because of kuvid 19.
it's not so bad at first now you've got
time to catch up on all those games on
your pile of shame a few weeks indoors
should be fun
right all right
next thing you know e3 is officially
canceled and gdc
is cancelled there's a travel ban
shelter in place begins and businesses
close their
doors you transition your work life
behind a computer screen your social
life
behind a computer screen and you install
this [ __ ] thing
you wear nice clothes every day to
create some sense of discipline
it doesn't last long suddenly like a ray
of sunshine piercing through hell's
gates
animal crossing and do maternal release
on the same exact day
soon your life becomes animal crossing
your friends become villagers animal
crossing becomes your life
your irl friends visit your island you
visit theirs and you desperately
struggle to understand nintendo's obtuse
goofy-ass voice chat choices
weddings happen in the game graduations
a talk show takes off
it feels good it almost feels
normal you think yeah i could get used
to this
oh yeah doom you're reminded of that
game you tried finishing on four
different occasions it gets a new and
expanded version
you're very happy for your friends who
love it but you come to terms with the
idea that you'll never finish it anyway
doom animal crossing doom animal
crossing doom
animal crossing
anyway half-life is back now it's april
the last of us part 2 is delayed from
may to june hello resident evil 3 remake
it's good but instead you beat resident
evil 2 remake for the 10th time
it's better also final fantasy 7 remake
actually comes out and it's a 10.
you're sensing a trend in april with
remakes here live shows are no longer a
thing but you can still see travis scott
perform in
fortnight straight up it's easter season
in animal crossing too there's eggs
everywhere and you never want to see
this bunny's
[ __ ] face or his eggs ever again the
day after easter you quit the game cold
turkey and never return for fear of
judgmental comments from your villagers
you still don't know what the ps5 looks
like but you've now seen its controller
you hope it comes in black you're sure
it'll come in black
right they've all come in black
you learn to solve a rubik's cube people
are super impressed and you feel smart
but give it a month neither you
nor anyone else will care one damn bit
may it's may
some games come out an open world rpg
about a revenge seeking shark
minecraft goes isometric dungeoncrawler
xenoblade chronicles gets a facelift
and amazon ventures into gaming with its
own hero shooter crucible
which you're damn sure is going to be
the next big thing
and then you remind yourself for the
268th time that amazon started as an
online book retailer you're astounded
yet again
let's just pause it for a moment this is
supposed to be a light-hearted video
looking back on the year but there's
some things you just simply can't tiptoe
around or
soften in any way in may george floyd
was murdered in an act of police
brutality
and has sent a shockwave around the
world hurling cities around the globe
into a state of civil unrest industry
leaders joined the conversation and
major gaming announcements were
postponed in the midst of a global
pandemic
the world underwent another upheaval as
people flooded the streets
in protest against police brutality and
the disproportionate killing of black
people black lives matter
okay
on with the show welcome to june
valerian is out
it's good yeah moving on the ps5
is revealed and well uh it's something
all right
it'll probably look better when they
show the black version in a few months
you're sure
the last of us part two is released and
despite the capital d
discourse is a thought-provoking sucker
punch of a game that sold bucket loads
sorry to keep stopping the video like
this but unfortunately we need to get
serious
again in june unchecked sexual
misconduct came to light in this
industry more clearly than ever before
most notably ubisoft was involved in a
sexual misconduct scandal
which resulted in many people being
removed from the company now
these are deplorable actions not held to
just one single company but it's
something that happens throughout the
gaming world
we love and we owe it to ourselves to
acknowledge it support the victims
and strive for more inclusive and safe
space okay
[ __ ] cyberpunk 2077 gets
delayed again from september to november
but really that's okay you're willing to
wait another two months
but not a second longer it's july halo
infinite is revealed to the world and uh
it doesn't go well but we get craig god
bless craig oh and that dude with the
jet pack
some of your friends are playing paper
mario the origami king others are
playing carrick
universally everyone gets metaphorically
drunk and goes to sushima's photo mode
deadly premonition 2's frame rate makes
you feel physically drunk so
you give it a 5 out of 10 and by you i i
mean
i mean me yeah it's august
fall guys tumbles into your heart
sending you down a rabbit hole of
nostalgia watching hours and hours of
mxc or takashi's castle for everyone
outside the states
ubisoft hops on the br hero shooter
bandwagon with hyperescape
okay cool and then microsoft flight
simulator comes out
are you looking at screenshots or is
that real life
is it real life no that's a screenshot
wait
is it spirit farewell reminds you what
it's like to feel things again
everything is delayed halo death loop
stanley parable deluxe but not cyberpunk
2077
no siree september phasmophobia catches
everyone off guard and scares the
absolute [ __ ] out of you
right here and gives us wonderful
moments like this
tony hawk's pro skater 1 and 2 remake
arise
thrusting you back into your awkward
tweens you buy a skateboard in a
desperate attempt to relive your glory
days
it doesn't go well
suddenly you realize that being a
30-something millennial taking up
skateboarding again is the equivalent of
a dad undergoing a mid-life crisis and
joining a motorcycle gang
the skateboard becomes a household
decoration suddenly the roguelike gets
very hot and
sexy you wake up the next morning in san
francisco turns orange raining ash from
the sky due in part to the forest fires
along northern california
you cope by pretending you're ryan
gosling and blade runner though in your
heart you know you're actually more
handsome than he is
genjin impact comes out wait is that is
that brother the wild
that one online bookstore announces its
own game streaming platform luna you
wonder how crucible is doing and out of
nowhere microsoft announces its
intention to acquire zenimax for
7.5 billion dollars you have questions
is elder scrolls going to be
an xbox exclusive can obsidian and
bethesda make another fallout baby what
would phil spencer todd howard's baby
look like
anyway it's october mario kart goes ar
and your cats
absolutely just love it there's a bunch
of games like crash bandicoot 4
surprisingly awesome star wars squadron
surprisingly awesome
i am dead surprisingly accurate amnesia
rebirth
surprisingly scary ghost runner
surprisingly tricky
super mario brothers 35 surprisingly shh
aoc proves that politicians can appear
human even when they're imposters
and this guy named corpse actually
sounds like a corpse
oh man my weak spot his voice is so teen
cyberpunk 2077 is absolutely
definitely coming out next month
november
cyberpunk 2077 is delayed 21 days
no but really you're actually kind of
relieved because there's new games
coming out and new consoles there's
assassin's creed valhalla watchdogs
legion yakuza like a dragon
bug snacks miles morales call of duty
black ops cold war
and hyrule warriors age of calamity
meanwhile people are
vaping into their xboxes you get the
series s and instead of playing anything
new
you play dead space again that is until
the ps5 comes out
two days later and you think about
making it black yourself
you get demon souls you now know what
true next-gen looks like until your ps5
shuts off during rest mode and you lose
your progress
it's patched all as well the book
website that made that hero shooter
crucible
shuts it down should have stuck the
books
immortals phoenix rising is really wait
is that that gentian impact the game
awards happen
and that game with the capital d
discourse that was reviewed bombed into
oblivion
sweeps the show and walks away with a
ton of awards and cyberpunk 2077
actually finally really comes out
on pc it looks fantastic it's a little
buggy but
you know nothing that can't be patched
consoles on the other hand
whoa is that the same game
then suddenly cyberpunk 2077 is
unreleased on the playstation store
due to its rocky performance and yet
still
it sells 13 million copies at launch
making it one of the most successful rpg
launches
of all time anyway gamespot awards
half-life alex as the game
of the year
[Music]
okay i think uh i think that just
about covers it now i know it's trite at
this point to comment on how
ridiculous this year has been and how
games have been the unifying thing for a
lot of us and i know there's good intent
behind that but
really video games
will likely be the zeitgeist for 2020
and
this is beyond just a social level but
this transcends
even in politics and going beyond just
mere
entertainment but actually becoming an
experience
at times and that is cool as hell
yeah okay i'm kurt devina this is
gamespot
subscribe if you haven't and happy new
year
here's to tomorrow the day after that
and the day after that and all that jazz
all right keep being sweet
[Music]
see